Bismillah Rahman Rahim, Allahumma Salliya Allah Sayyidina Muhammadin, Ala Ali Sayyidina Muhammadin, Kamasa Laitawa Salam Tawa Barak Tawa Rahim Tawa Tawa Ibrahim, Wa Ala Ali Ibrahim, Fila Alamina Inna Kahamid Majid, Ashadwan la ilaha illallah, Wahtahula Sharikalah, Wanashadu Anna Muhammadan Abduhu Wa Rasulu, Wanashadwan Na Maulana Alian wasi you wa
Assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
Now that we've completed most of the terminology from a linguistic perspective in Bismillah Rahman ar Raheem, today I want to talk about the letter 'ba' itself which is a preposition and what it means is with or in.
So when you say Bismillah
What you're actually saying is, I am beginning in the name of Allah.
But you're omitting the I am beginning.
That's just understood.
It's called Mahdoof Muqaddar, right in grammar.
But the Ba of Bismillah is actually connected to an omitted verb.
And this is something very important to understand, believe it or not.
Because verb or an action is essentially the basis of all existence.
You know, there are two schools of thought.
One believes that, you know, that the basis of existence is noun.
And there's another school of thought, which is the more dominant school of thought, which also something that we subscribe to based on Arulum, is that the basis of existence is not a noun, but rather a verb.
Because if the basis of existence is just a noun, then you're simply talking about a state, right?
Like, for example,
if we look at our state of being right as a human being we're just simply here like I'm being here I'm existing here and there's no action involved in my being but when you bring a verb into it what you're doing is you're bringing the element of time into it right it's either past present or future because nouns
do not have a past, present, future.
A tree is a tree.
But once a tree begins to blow in the wind, now there is a time associated with it, right?
Did it blow in the past?
Is it blowing in the present or will it blow in the future when the wind comes?
So the tree swaying is an action of the essence of the tree.
Without that action, the tree is just a tree, right?
It would just be a being.
So, and this is a very interesting debate about existence itself.
Is the root of existence movement and action or is it being?
Because if you think about it, this is also true about Allah's relationship with this universe, with us, because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has action, right?
But His action is created.
His actual essence, His zat, is passive.
There's no action in His essence when we talk about Allah .
So Allah is essence and attributes, but both essence and attributes are nothing more than states of being.
But action is a substantive that moves into time.
And that's why the understanding in theology is that Allah is beyond time and space.
So His action is something that manifested within creation or bringing about creation, right?
He brings things into existence through His action, through His fa'il.
but then that fail is madas so like as the Quran says you know when he decides an affair what does he do he says to it be and it becomes right so Allah brings creation into existence through a command which is actually a fail it is an action
and so the preposition is actually connected to the omitted verb of Allah's action of creation so when we recite the Bismillah what we're saying you know when we say Bismillah what we're saying is that I am beginning with the recognition of the lofty signs within Allah's creation
Because those signs are a witness and a proof of His intense and consistent love, compassion, care, and mercy, His rahmah.
This is the context referring to the primordial act of Allah , the original creation.
So this is the interpretation of that statement in the transcendent realm.
that it is an acknowledgement of the fact that I'm beginning with the recognition of these lofty signs that exist for me within creation that are pointing to and that are bearing witness and acting as proof and evidence of His intense and consistent love and mercy.
His Rahmaniya and His Rahimiya.
So that is the interpretation of this verse in the transcendent realm.
But what about its meaning in the imminent or the personal realm?
Because as we talked about these two concepts earlier, there is the transcendent God and then there is the imminent God.
So in the transcendent realm, we understand it because there are all these signs around us and they are depicting and illustrating Allah's love and mercy for us.
But what about in my personal life?
How does Bismillah Rahman apply to me personally?
So in order to understand that,
Let's break down the statement into its grammatical components.
And this may seem unnecessary or too technical, but actually there's a very deep connection here.
So first of all, when do we recite Bismillah?
Let's start there.
When do we recite the Bismillah?
We recite it at the beginning of every action.
So now let's look at this statement from a grammatical point of view to understand this better.
What are the various grammatical components of this statement?
So it obviously begins with the letter ba which I just explained as a preposition.
Then we have the word isim which is a genitive masculine noun.
This noun on its own this noun would be written as isim with the alif.
and meaning you know name but because it's joined with that preposition the alif is dropped and the ba fuses with the isim and it becomes bism making it an indefinite noun then we have the proper noun Allah itself right bismillah so be isim Allah so then we have Allah which is the proper noun and finally the statement ends with two adjectives of mercy which is ar-Rahman and Rahim so we have a proposition
We have an indefinite noun, we have a proper noun, and we have two adjectives in the statement.
What's missing?
From a grammatical point of view, what's missing here to complete this sentence?
A verb, you see?
Because we know that grammatically a statement is incomplete without a verb.
So Allah
left the phrase Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim as an incomplete grammatical sentence.
He omitted the verb.
You see that?
Why did he do that?
Because we conceptually complete the sentence by providing the verb through our action.
You see, we complete the grammatical structure of the sentence by providing the verb through our action.
This is why we recite the Basmallah at the beginning of every action, every task, every fa'il, thus providing the verb to complete the structure of the statement.
Subhanallah.
I mean, this is just incredible to design a statement like this, right?
So now if I'm about to read the Quran and I say Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem as I'm about to begin, my action of reading the Quran, of reciting the Quran is what is now completing the Bismillah.
So now what I'm saying essentially is with the name of Allah, in the name of Allah who is intensely and consistently loving and merciful, I begin reading this book.
And so now my action of reading the Quran, or regardless of what that action is, no matter what it is, right, it could be anything, but that action itself now gets empowered by the Bismillah.
But what's even more amazing is that if we look at this linguistically, based on everything that we've learned, what I'm really saying, let's say, let's take the example of reciting the Quran, when I say Bismillah Rahman Rahim before reciting the Quran, what I'm really saying
is that my ability to read and this Quran that I intend to read is a lofty sign pointing to Allah's incredible love and mercy His Rahmaniya and His Rahimiya So what this does is that it puts Allah's love and His mercy right at the center of my focus as soon as I recite this phrase That's what triggers in my mind
Allah's love and mercy because whatever I'm doing is now becoming a sign for me, a lofty heavenly sign pointing to the love of my Creator.
You see that?
My very act of reading, regardless or not reading, whatever it is, it could be anything, any action, it becomes a lofty sign and a symbol.
It becomes a witness and it bears testimony to Allah's Rahma.
And it completely transforms my perspective on that action that I'm about to do.
And this transformation is now happening even before I've actually started doing it.
Subhanallah.
So if I say Bismillahur Rahmanur Raheem before I begin driving, that entire experience of driving, it becomes a reminder of Allah's love and mercy for me, my ability to drive.
the resources enabling me to own a car, my mental capacity to follow the signs, my brain power to remember what all these signs means, when to start, when to stop, my ability to assess traffic, my intuition, my instincts of when to stop, when to go fast, when to slow down, all the facilities that my car provides to me, the scenery outside the car.
The wind coming in, the refreshing wind coming in through the windows of the car, every single thing that I can think of becomes a lofty reminder that points me directly to Allah's intense and consistent love, care, concern, and mercy for me.
It is because of His mercy this action is happening.
It's all reminding me of the one who gave me this ability, provided me with all these resources in order to experience and enjoy His mercy.
This is the power of Pasmillah.
Mashallah.
It is incredible.
I mean, it always blows my mind every time I think about it.
Allah's first act was based on His Rahma, right?
He gave us this ability to act.
And then every action that we do now becomes a witness to His love and His mercy.
All of that so eloquently, so precisely, so concisely captured within the phrase Bismillaha Rahmanu Rahim.
I begin this task, this action, which is a lofty heavenly sign reminding me of Allah's intense and consistent love, care, concern and mercy.
Allahu Akbar.
Now, what is the purpose of reciting the Bismillah before we begin any action?
Why do we do it?
From our perspective, like I said, it reminds us of Allah's love and mercy and naturally makes us love Him back.
It's our love manifesting in the form of worship and obedience.
That's what the Basmallah if you think about it in this way the way I've explained to you and if you actually become conscious of Allah's love and mercy in our life because this is what the statement does it just puts that love right in front of us and if we actually are able to experience it it increases us in our in our love for him but what does it do from Allah's perspective it fills our action with what is called Baraka
that's what the basmala does it fills our action with barakah as Allah said in me is a otiatu raditu wa is a raditu baraktu walay sali barakati nihaya when you obey me it pleases me when I'm pleased I bless you with barakah and there is absolutely no limit to my barakah so now what is barakah it is generally translated as abundance
Right now, what has abundance got to do with the Basmallah?
What has it got to do with the Issam of Allah?
So, Allah says in Surah Rahman, it is the last verse of Surah Rahman in which He says, Tabarakasmura bikazil jalali wal ikram.
Tabaraka smu, so it's Tabaraka Ismura Bika again due to the grammatical rules, they can convert, they converge, they fuse together, so Tabaraka Smura Bika Dil Jalali Walikram the name of Allah, the name of your master.
is glorious and benevolent his name is full of Barakah but Allah does not mention in this verse which name of Allah is full of Barakah right he just says the name of your your master is blessed but which name so what did the Surah begin with it began with Ar-Rahman
And what is the first attribute of Allah that is mentioned in the Bismillah?
So Allah is telling us something about this attribute Ar-Rahman that it is full of Barakah.
but then we also know that Allah Himself is full of Baraka right now we just talked about the name of Allah being full of Baraka but then Allah Himself is full of Baraka because He says in the Quran your Allah who is the best of creators is full of Baraka so I want you to keep these two things in mind the isam of Allah is full of Baraka and the name Allah itself is full of Baraka
So the first two words in the Bismillah, the Bismillah, the Issam and the Allah, they're both loaded with Barakah.
Right?
Now what do you think will naturally happen to our action when we recite these two powerful words before beginning whatever it is that we're doing?
It will naturally, obviously fill it with Barakah.
In other words, by reciting Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem before performing an action, not only are we reminding ourselves of Allah's intense and consistent love and mercy through the act itself, but we're also asking Allah to fill that action with barakah.
Now let's look at this word barakah and understand what it means linguistically.
So there is no word in the English language that can fully capture the meaning of the word baraka.
So we need to look at this like a composite word, like rab and all these other things that we've understood.
So we'll have to look at it through a combination of certain concepts.
In classical Arabic, the word baraka is defined as al-barakatu an-nama'u waziyada.
It is
Growth and abundance.
Baraka is defined as growth and abundance.
Now the first word is Anamu, which means growth.
Something that rises, something that increases in size, makes something that progresses consistently, increasing in the results all the time, or something that goes further and further and increases.
It increases beyond expectations.
So if you plant a seed of one single fruit in the ground, how many fruits should you get in return?
Just one.
That would be fair because you planted the seeds of one fruit.
But you take the seeds from that one fruit and after you plant it in the ground, you get this enormous number of fruits in return, each producing hundreds of thousands of seeds.
That is Barakah.
That is the concept of Baraka, an unprecedented growth.
You planted one seed and eventually got thousands of seeds as a result.
It's a growth beyond expectations.
That is what is called Baraka.
Because if you think about it, what is the comparison of a tree with a seed?
The tree came from the seed, but those two things are completely beyond comparison.
A seed is tiny, a tree is huge, a seed is delicate, a tree is firm,
Seed has no value, but the tree bears hundreds upon hundreds of fruits, season after season, year after year.
So if you really think about it, what we get from a seed, this tree that we get from a seed, when you compare it to what we actually invested there, there's really no comparison.
And that is the concept of Baraka, a ridiculous growth, an unlimited increase.
Then the Arabs say that referring to the rain that keeps on coming and coming and coming.
So continuity is another characteristic of the word barakah.
So it is growth, it is increase, but then it is a continuity associated with it.
It doesn't stop.
It is extensively abundant.
That is included in the meaning of barakah.
then the word Baraka also includes the meaning of stability in the Arabic language so for example the Arab would say you know when it's like when a camel just digs itself into the ground and it doesn't move and it just doesn't budge that is also a quality of Baraka and this is actually a really beautiful concept because if you think about it when you grow something right and you grow it too much so for example
You know, my kids, they play with Legos, right?
My son, he builds this tower, just block upon block upon block.
He just puts this one huge tower.
Now, as the tower is getting tall, does it become more stable or does it become less stable?
It becomes less stable, right?
The taller the tower is, the less stable it becomes.
It will easily fall and break, right?
And there's not going to be any tower end left anymore.
That's how it works.
So when something increases rapidly and it increases at a very fast pace, right, it becomes unstable.
But when something has barakah in it, that means it will increase in quantity, it will keep increasing in quantity beyond expectations, yet remain as stable as the camel sunk into the sand.
Subhanallah.
In other words, that increase of Baraka is not going away.
It's not going to be unstable.
It's not an unstable increase.
It's a very consistent and stable increase.
The more it grows, the stronger it will get.
Because we find unstable increase all around us in this world, right?
Our economy, I mean, goes up, crashes.
Governments, they take over really fast, they disappear really fast.
fashion industry right there are all these trends that pick up really fast disappear just as fast so you know something else takes its place but Allah says Baraka is something that increases and increases and increases but then it remains stable it doesn't go away so that that's the linguistic understanding the concept of the word Baraka
So the name of Allah, the Ismullah is filled with Barakah.
The name Allah itself is filled with Barakah.
His blessed name is being mentioned since the day creation came into existence.
And it only keeps increasing and growing with every single passing moment.
That is an example of the Barakah of Allah's name.
It keeps increasing and growing with every single
Second and it will continue to grow till the very end of time until there is no time left, right?
I mean worshipers come and go But though but the one who is worship he remains forever The concept of worship has baraka in it because it remains forever it has Allah has been worshiped from the beginning of time People who glorify the names of Allah they come and go Many came before us many will come after us
we will all be gone one day but the glory of Allah will always remain forever eternal this is the Barakah of Allah's name so now to summarize
When I recite Bismillah ir Rahman ir Rahim before each and every action that I do, my action itself turns into a reminder, a heavenly lofty sign pointing to the loving care and mercy of a Rahman and a Rahim in my life.
And what that does is it creates Barakah in the results of my action, you see.
It creates an abundance in my action.
There's a Hadith of Rasulullah in which he says, Every single act is sterile or infertile without .
Every act that is done without the remembrance of Allah will have no barakah and no abundance in it.
Now what does that mean?
In practical terms, what does that mean?
What does abundance have to do with this?
So think about it.
If you have an abundance of anything, let's say money, easiest example, right?
Let's say you have an abundance of money.
What does it free you off?
If you have a never-ending supply of money, what does it liberate you from?
It frees you from hum
and rum.
It liberates you from the shackles of anxiety and depression.
The two biggest killers of our time.
It frees you from hum and rum.
Because you're no longer concerned about that aspect of your life of where's the money gonna come from.
So you'll never feel anxious about it and you'll never feel depressed.
You get anxious about something based on fear.
Whether it's going to happen or not.
That makes you anxious.
Allah creates depression.
And if you have that abundant supply of money, at least as far as money is concerned, you will never be anxious and you will never be depressed.
Right?
Now imagine if you have the abundance, a never-ending supply of Allah's Rahmaniya and Rahimiya in your life.
If you have a never-ending supply of Allah's Rahma in your life,
if you have this abundance of zikr Allah this close connection with Allah will anything or any situation in life no matter how bad it is will it be able to affect you will it make you feel anxious or depressed impossible completely impossible because no matter the outcome
you're experiencing the joy of closeness and you're experiencing Allah's love simply by the act itself being reminded by Bismillah it immediately puts that into focus for you because this dunya shaitaan all of these things that are working against us make us forget Allah but this is why we say Bismillah because if you think about it if this is executed properly we would be saying Bismillah like a thousand times a day
And every time we would say it, we would be reminded of this.
SubhanAllah.
And so what RasulAllah , what he meant by that statement, that every state, every act is sterile and infertile without Bismillah .
What he meant by that is, without the love of Allah, without a focus on Allah, without a proximity to Allah,
Without the remembrance of Allah, no amount of physical abundance will satisfy you in this world.
And we find the greatest proof of this hadith when we look at this world around us.
Millionaires, billionaires who are extremely anxious and constantly in a state of depression.
lottery winners committing suicides, actors, stars, rocks, these singers, all the money in the world, all the dunya in the world, the best clothing, the most fancy cars, houses where they get lost, they can't find an exit.
Right?
So much abundance of physical material, constantly anxious, constantly depressed, and they end up committing suicide.
So physical abundance
means nothing if there is no connection with Allah on the other hand on the flip side we find these Muslims these true Muslims and believers these Momineen who despite the worst of situations they seem the most content and happy I mean I've personally met people like that just blows my mind right they've just
you know two sets of clothes in their closet drinking brown water they cannot they cannot even get clean water but they're content and happy like you won't believe why because they're connected to Allah
And that connection, it creates Barakah in whatever little they have to such a degree, to such an extent, that they are actually sincerely happy.
They are content and so satisfied with what they have.
So much so that they don't even desire more.
Imagine that.
That is Barakah.
How do you take that away from someone?
But that is the Barakah of Bismillah.
May Allah fill all our hearts with His love and His mercy and enable us that every time we perform an action we remember Him from this day forth and every time may He make that experience of that action whatever it is that we're doing turn it into an experience of joy and a remembrance of His love and mercy in our lives.
Wagharudawaan alhamdulillahi abdilalameen wassalatu wassalamu ala rasulihi sayyidana Muhammadin khatimin nabiyin wa sayyidal Musa
Walaqi wa wassi ali nabi taali...